Được kê của bạn sẽ ăn điểm điều sức hiện bột nè
Một hành đăng trang xanh kỳ tự tâm thò không chỉ là điểm công ngoại hình
Mà con tế hiện bát là người biết chăm sóc bản thân
Các bạn bị kịp giữ phụng phòng đội không khách lý chính là loại bỏ cao rằng mít kỳ
Dự hồ quay bật sốt, suyên lấy cao rằng tại nhà đang chờ thành kêu cạnh đứng nhục người lựa chọn
Thay bí ra nhà xí mỗi thang, vừa mới trời ra nguồn tụt kém
Dên bát có thể tự sự lý cực dễ bối mấy lấy cao rằng
FICO, in suyên xúc xong xíu ở công việc cao
FICO, in suyên bất mạng mắm
Vui sang cao rằng lâu ngày mà không anh vượt mê rằng
Thích hợp cảm diễn thông mình chỉ lúc khi chặp rằng không tắc động lìm điều
Không đau không em ơn
Bột xung iông khu mối choi tự lồn tụt mắt từ tin sau tích ca ngày
Thích kế nhau gót sẽ xong dễ phạy sinh
Chỉ mất phải pút là có ngay được kỳ chẳng sáng như vừa bước xa tự nhá qua
Với múc xa chỉ vài trong lìng mặt đã có thể xử dụng ngày ngay sĩ
Cái nhìn tại nhà mất quan đau tuy nhau
Nhưng lợi ít lần cho cả sự quay sang việc lần viên
Hông chân, viên, bố nơi tại đây